right now I'm in Canberra staying on you
for the national mathematics summer
school walking through the university
grounds reminded me about my own years
at uni when I was at uni staying to
become a teacher I read a lot of
research in my course about the nature
of intelligence as this graduating and
TQ freely while it hasn't thought about
that so I want to talk to you today
about where the intelligence is fixed or
fluid at the idea of fixing times
is there a basically smart people
basically dumb people and I'll whole
spectrum in between but whatever you are
you more or less stay that way for your
entire life
now educational researchers also talk
about fixed types of intelligence which
means that people are born with the
innate ability to understand some things
but not others and the idea of fixed
intelligence is that those abilities are
very hard to change fluid intelligence
on the other hand is all about the idea
that our intelligence can shift and
change not just suddenly but
dramatically over time and given
different stimuli this idea has gotten a
lot of currency recently because of
neurological research that has shown the
brain isn't as physiologically static
organ which is what people thought up
for a long time now you might have heard
of the term neuroplasticity which refers
to the brain's ability to develop new
pathways and sign apses in response to
certain behaviors and environmental
factors
now fluid intelligence I think is kind
of like the Disney approach to mental
ability which is you know you can become
anything if you believe in yourself
mostly this sounds pretty academic but
the truth is that most people regular
guys on the street but leaving a fixed
or fluid intelligence to some degree
okay now take fixed intelligence often
when I introduce myself as a math
teacher people will say oh I've never
been a very maths kind of person okay
now there's an assumption underneath
that statement namely that there are
maths people and non maths people and
that's an unchangeable quality battery
that can't be altered and that's fixed
intelligence right
on the other hand I've also had
conversations with lots of parents who
express confusion at their children
having difficulty with maths you know
may seem to be under the impression that
if you force someone to do enough
exercises and put them in enough
cheering sessions then they have to be
come better at maths or science or
English or whatever their expectation is
that their child's brain should be
endlessly malleable given the right
inputs and that's fluid intelligence the
interesting thing for me about the whole
fixed fluid intelligence argument is
that it's really practical right as a
teacher it is a massive impact on how I
approach my students on a day-to-day
basis
do I not bother with some students
because I know they'll just never get it
or do I push some relentlessly because I
know they're capable of understanding
things they haven't even heard of yet
now before I go on what do you think do
you think intelligence is mainly fixed
or mainly fluid right now the thought
I'm having is yes yes it is fixed in
some respects and fluid in others
and to put it differently intelligence I
think is flexible it can definitely
can't even grow but it has real limits
and we should be ok with that and in my
experience the people who've said yeah
I'm not a maths kind of person it
probably had a bad experience or an
unhelpful teacher at one point in their
life and since they're they've given up
on understanding all the X's and Y's and
derivatives because it's just been more
trouble and it's worth but if they give
it a real go with the right help they'd
probably be able to understand way more
than they ever thought possible
intelligence is not as fixed as many
people think it is at the same time I
think that every human brain does have
its own unique personality and desires
and mental strengths that we ought to
recognize you know some people do
understand patterns better and more
quickly well others need to struggle
with them a bit longer some people are
able to turn a beautiful phrase or pick
the best camera angle with very little
training while others require more
guidance before they have those skills
yeah and that's okay as part of what
makes us individuals and we should
embrace that rather than thinking that
everyone has to be good at the same
things for your maths on physics or
English so what kind of Intel does do
you have embrace of what it is but
always remember to push the envelope and
challenge yourself to try things that
seem out of reach
you might surprise yourself